stop the tracks are worn down on my
microphone and it's infuriating which i
guess is why i got a new one
hi everyone i'm alan and welcome to my
channel where um i don't think i've ever
made a video
that's my camera is this far away but i
kind of changed my setup and got a desk
that is separate to my gaming desk so
you know
and i basically for black friday cyber
monday there are a bunch of things that
i've been wanting to buy for a while to
kind of upgrade my setup decided to wait
uh to see if they were on sale and then
bought a bunch of them so i thought that
really just because people ask me so
often what kind of gear i use what kind
of microphone i use
um i thought that i would just show you
guys some of the
upgrades that i made and kind of why i'm
going to be completely changing my
microphone setup which i'm very happy
about um let me give you a bit of this
with no
audio editing what i use right now is a
roadie pro caster
and um first box up here
it's great very easy to edit out the
background noise that comes with it but
it does always have
a lot of noise so i am upgrading to a
new microphone after using this one for
i think four years and i'm very excited
about the upgrade because it should make
my
um audio editing life a lot easier so
first things first i lately have been
using since i
went to the fun house office to go and
pick them up these are
um the windows surface headphones
i absolutely love these i think they're
awesome they're super comfy
they have noise cancelling fantastic
i've owned these for ages though
but i realized that i did not have any
convenience stand for them and because
my monitor is so big
and i have an xbox right here there's a
switch behind there and then there's a
light
for when i record stuff i decided to
properly get a stand for them so that is
the first purchase that we made this is
the base station chroma mercury headset
stand with usb hub usb hub is a really
appealing part of this to me because i
feel like i need
usbs all the time so let's open this one
up shall we this is the
the base right here peel that plastic
off beautiful
[Music]
so here's your stand with the usb
and then i'm gonna throw these on here
and that's what my uh
my stand is gonna be i really like it i
think this is just really clean
okay it's in the corner for now i will
have to move that at some point
the light's super cooler i really like
it so the second thing is something that
i already own
that i am replacing uh because
mine's really dirty it is the mat that i
have right here just put some stuff away
um but yeah because i've been using it
for like three years i think
it just it just got dirty over time and
i did try to wash it and failed
miserably um i think that i probably
will keep it and try to wash it a little
bit better i was scared of breaking it
to be honest
but i basically bought a replacement for
it because i'm a very big fan of this
mat
uh i guess it is called the goliath
extended krama
i do love me some chroma it's pretty
much just
a really big mouse pad she big
and much cleaner than this one which is
like brown now it's
awful so let's start
unplugging stuff shall we it's so
dirty i like kind of didn't even realize
how dirty it was because
i most often have my mouse on it oh my
god
disgust i think i should just throw this
out you've served me well sir but
yikes also it's my own fault for
drinking
coffee on it so much i just need to put
the coffee on here
and then we're okay replacing that made
so much difference it's honestly just
sort of funny
wow i've been living in filth next up
let me show you this beautiful baby
a g-force the light went out beautiful
brilliant love it a geforce rtx 3080
from nvidia yeah a very due for an
upgrade um
and very very very excited to have this
this one was sent by nvidia
so this is the only thing of all of the
stuff that i'm showing you today that i
did not purchase
huge thanks to nvidia the amount of
things that have gotten difficult on
this pc so fast
is absurd so very excited to have this
in time for cyberpunk and look at the
presentation
like isn't this just beautiful
i think it's beautiful it's quite big
but because my pc is open case
it's absolutely gonna fit pretty much no
worries where that's concerned so that's
another one then i guess we have company
number three sitting down the bottom
here one more box
once i get this out i will move the
camera to start doing setup stuff
basically
so this box contains um stuff that i
bought more off of personal
recommendations from friends than
anything else if i'm being honest
uh we basically have the
elgato wave 3 i also got a shock mount
and a pop filter all the stuff that i
need for a new microphone but yeah it
comes with mixing software that i'm very
excited about
it seems super cool and it says it is
tailored for creators like obviously
built for
the streaming i don't know if you've
caught any of my streams where people
often complain that there's like a hum
in the background that i don't seem to
be able to do anything about
ideally the wave 3 gets rid of that
i'm excited to see what size it actually
is i've not seen one of these in person
i've only seen them in other people's
videos so
okay tiny box inside of a box again a
terrible unboxing i have a whole table
here and i'm not even using it
got your cables there here
is the microphone
itself hmm it is very
very sleek um got a bunch of controls on
here there's a mute button up the top
which i think is really neat
and your headphone input yeah this
thing's
so small and so light that's very cool
keep that stand obviously uh pop filter
this is for your plosives for your p
sounds that uh they pop basically
this is all like packaged so nicely i'm
very impressed with how um
how sleek it all is it's really
tidy and and just again just so light
like i'm used to microphones being these
annoying
this is good
being these like annoying heavy
cumbersome things this is um
i'm very happy with the way this has
been designed so we're probably going to
want to put this on here
like so i imagine it's so easy to attach
this is great and i'm a fan okay so the
last thing we have is the suspension
mount this thing looks
cool as hell too wow that was easy
this i love this design
i guess we still got to test how well it
works
so i think it's time for me to swap
cameras
and um probably also swap microphones
[Music]
okay let's see how it sounds shall we
okay we have a new microphone and this
is me testing it
um it's obviously very far off to the
side which isn't always going to be
necessary
but because of my super ultra wide
monitor and the way the stand is i feel
like it's better over there so we'll see
if it sounds okay or if it sounds odd
because it is only getting you know one
side of my mouth
it's great or if maybe i do need to use
the stand with the extended to have it
in front of me um i don't know i'm going
to listen back to this video and see
what i think
yeah it's excited also it required like
no setup
i just plugged it in and it worked so
you love to see it
you love to see it i just hit myself in
the nose i feel like there was like a
little bit of popping there
and then let's see if there's any noise
because that'll i'll be able to hear it
there is a tiny bit of noise from it
still but i don't doubt that there are a
bunch of settings that i can play with
uh this is great this is great and i am
a fan i will obviously play with it much
more extensively
um other than just this initial setup
but for now the fact that it can it can
sit to the side and record me just fine
without covering my screen is awesome we
are happy
with the elgato microphone and i will
now be using it for the rest of the
video
and then at some other point we'll
actually look in
its back end and play with the settings
and turn the noise filter on and
and get all that stuff done but it is
immediately
um much crisper sounds much better so
we're happy with this this is good stuff
all right
let me zoom out
i've now put so you guys can see it my
headset stand on the corner of the desk
here
which i really like it's perfect doesn't
get in the way of anything microphone is
perfect
i think this setup looks fantastic um
but for now it's time to break my pc by
replacing my graphics card
which means that there will be no good
audio sorry about that
let's do it though i'm excited let's do
it can't wait to never use my pc again
all right it's gonna look like a mess
down here for a while because it is
but the first step of this beautiful
game is unplugging literally everything
[Music]
[Music]
and that my friends is how you install a
graphics card
not too shabby
[Music]
[Music]
okay here it is
um i can definitely fix up some of this
cable management on the sides which i
will get to but
for the most part that's how it looks
fits in the case
perfectly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alrighty everyone drivers have been
updated
new microphone new headset
beautiful monitor as always and then
we've got
a 3080 down in here um but it won't
quite look right until i turn the lights
off so just give me a second
i'll probably have more updates about
how i'm liking the microphone when i've
been able to play with it more
and i will definitely have many a video
showing off the 3080 huge thanks to
nvidia for giving me that one though
this is not a sponsored video
um i made this anyway but
may have already published some of the
sponsored stuff for them
but yeah that is my choices for my 2020
um gaming setup upgrade thank you all
for watching bye